[Music]
so I woke up this morning and was
pleasantly surprised to see that there
was a new Captain Marvel trailer which
had been put out by Marvel Australia and
Wow it really blew me away for someone
that was slightly disappointed by the
first trailer I have to say that this
completely rectified my thoughts on the
film what this trailer does expertly is
that it defines the tone of the film as
well as setting up a lot of the key
characters and their role something that
I feel was missing from the first
trailer it clearly highlights that
Captain Marvel has a heavy bout of
amnesia and I think as the story
progresses we will learn more about her
past in the sword
Batman Begins way instead of having all
of the events chronologically I also
think the CGI work on samuel l.jackson
space looks fantastic and this is by far
the best da ting that they've done
across the board by the looks of it he's
gonna play a major part in the film and
it'll definitely be interesting to see
if this effect holds up throughout
tonally this looks like a cross between
guardians of the galaxy and Iron Man
both of which are some of my favorite
MCU movies so yes I'm very hyped for it
judging by the dialogue - they are
clearly defining and introducing the
Scrolls heavily so it seems like these
will certainly be the next big villain
for the MCU going forward Ben Mendelsohn
appears under scroll makeup so it's
pretty clear that they're going to
introduce the race's shape-shifting
powers and I can imagine this carrying
forward with the reveal of one of our
heroes from The Avengers
being a scroll in a later film and this
kind of sets it up really nicely this
space battle to look epic and I know
there was some worry that we would not
get the red and blue classic costume in
the film so I'm glad this clears it up
overall this trailer has massively
piqued my interest and I know we were
meant to be getting Avengers for this
week so if they drop that then hey
amazing week to be a comic book fan but
yeah definitely had for this movie and I
can't wait to see what they deliver so
what are your thoughts on the new
Captain Marvel trailer does it get you
hyped for the film and what you hope to
see in it comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video and then
please like it and check out my world
first review of the bumblebee
which would be linked at the end of this
video this is the channel for people who
are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]